you feel the people have maligned you're
been assassinated I have been buried
alive
emotions were high as our Kelly breaks
his silence in his first TV interview
since his arrest denying all sexual
abuse allegations including those
documented in lifetime surviving our
Kelly docu-series
yeah the singer sat down with CBS this
morning's Gayle King and she did not
hold back with her questions et is
breaking down the most explosive moments
have you done anything that you regret
have you done anything wrong lots of
things wrong when it comes to women that
I apologized but I apologized in those
relationships at the time I was in the
relationships they broken any laws when
it comes to women absolutely Gayle
admits she found that hard to believe
Kelly was charged with ten counts of
aggravated sexual abuse and three of the
alleged victims were underage yeah and
of course one of the most explosive
moments in this interview though was his
breakdown
midway through now et exclusively talked
to Gayle King this morning she had this
to say about some of those intense
moments you know it's it's a type of
emotion that was so intense that at one
point the producer suggested should we
stop the interview and he was very
adamant no I don't want the interview to
stop his person came and tried and
claims no I don't want Kleenex this
person came and said settle down settle
down Robert leave me alone
where's the camera I want people to hear
me so he he was very much aware of what
he was doing but I also thought that on
some level we were watching someone who
was really needed help and needed help
right away
I was never afraid I never thought that
our Kelly was going to hurt me I knew
that he was upset with me I knew
that he didn't like some of the
questions but I never thought that he
was going to physically attack me
I never thought that I was only
concerned because he was so amped up and
very angry that he might accidentally
hit me so I did worry about that we will
have more from Gayle later in this video
so stay tuned but back to the
allegations facing Kelly the singer's
ex-wife Andrea Kelly spoke out in the
six-part dr. Sears and opened up about
his estranged relationship with their
kids it's because of you Robert that my
children were told they can't sit at the
lunch table cuz your daddy rates little
girls you can deny all you want to and
for that you can go to hell you're
saying everything they said in that
documentary about you is not true they
are lying on me why would these women
say the same thing about you that you
are controlling that you are abusive
that you tell women when to eat when to
go to the bathroom when they can see
where they can dress you can start a
rumor on a guy like me or celebrity just
like that all you have to do is push a
button on your phone and say so-and-so
did this to me are Kelly did this to me
and if you get any traction from that at
you if you're able to write a book from
that if you're able to get a reality
show then any girl that I had a
relationship in the past that I it just
didn't work out she can come and say the
same exact thing so he has a point here
in many cases people do create these you
know false narratives about celebrities
to gain fame but in my opinion I don't
think that's what we're dealing with
here in light of all these claims
against him now this part made my
stomach turn when I watch the Doc you
series all of the alleged victims their
stories were so consisting I will say
this though our Kelly did clarify why
he's speaking out it's not to save his
career but to fight for his rights and
his relationship with his kids I want a
relationship with my kids cuz I have
missed a lot of years their life they
love me I love them and they want a
relationship with you that you they do
yeah
my bra phony you have daughters if your
daughters called you and said that
somebody is doing to them what they'll
let what the allegations are about you
would you be okay with that I'm gonna
tell you still might be up in that
mother everything up I had to believe
myself but I was if your daughters came
to you and said look this guy is doing
to me what the allegations are getting
out then I would have to arrest myself
out idea what I had to do now that
reaction is the reaction any father
should have they should be passionate
about their own daughters safety but
what doesn't sit well is there's so many
claims of him being in the public eye
with underage girls including Allium and
I saw that firsthand
you know after these years of
accusations wouldn't our Kelly sure his
side of the story with this I mean
they're still estranged yeah and
obviously that's their private life so
we're not involved in that but I would
have loved to see him go a little bit
deeper in the interview on that part of
things right and the docu-series of
course did paint a picture that he's
untouchable that he keeps getting
acquitted through and through again and
that he's always maintained his
innocence and to be fair I do appreciate
him saying he does not feel invincible
that he is human it could be to save
face but he still did say that exactly
you have never held anybody against
their will I don't need to think why
would i well I'm out stupid with never
helping our Kelly with all I've been
through in my way waiting pass to hold
somebody let alone four five six fifty
you see it what how stupid would I be to
do that I didn't say yes guys I didn't
is this camera on me yes that's stupid
use your common sense so let's talk
about are Kelly's behavior here the
shouting he's really emotional and Gail
seemed to really hold her own as a
journalist as he's raising his voice I
mean it has to be an emotional moment
for everyone in the room and actually
she told et beforehand that she went to
go visit his apartment and sort of say
hellos before the interview started
because she wanted not to sit down to be
the first moment where they had any sort
of interaction yeah I will say one thing
I appreciated in addition to her candor
is that he said he was willing to go to
therapy to get some help
what he thinks he needs to go to therapy
for is to be determined but Gail also
appreciated that he said that he's very
broken in many ways but he's also very
strong I walked away thinking that you
know he was given the opportunity to
tell his side of the story and also
walked away thinking I really hope that
he that he reflects on what he said he's
going to reflect on and it maybe he will
get some help so there's still a lot to
dig into you guys et has learned are
Kelly is expected in court today he has
to make a six-figure child support
payment or else he was going back to
jail so we will keep you updated with
all the latest as part two of this
interview unfolds until next time I'm
Katie Krause and I'm QWERTY tezo
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]